The words virtual and virtualization are
popular these days. From virtual worlds and
virtual reality to applications level virtual machines
like Dalvik or Java's virtual machine. What
we are concerned with here are virtual platforms. And by platform we mean an
operating system running on top of some hardware. Let's say Alice has her own
company, Alice Inc. And she has some cool applications to run for productivity.
And let's say that they're running on a Windows
machine, on some server that the company maintains. Now,
if cost were not an issue, then this will be the ideal situation for Alice
Inc. The hope of virtualization is that we will
be able to give a company perhaps not as well
endured as Alice Inc., let's's say Bala Inc., almost the
same experience that Alice Inc., gets at a fraction of the
cost. So, instead of a real platform that Alice Inc., has,
Bala Inc., gets a virtual platform. Now, in this diagram,
what I've shown you is a black box
to represent the virtual platform. Because, so far as
Bala Inc., is concerned, they don't really care what
goes on inside this black box? All they want
is to make sure that the apps that they want to run can run on top of this
virtual platform. in other words, as long as the
platform affords the same capabilities and the same abstractions
for running the applications that Bala Inc., wants he is happy. Now,
we however as aspiring operating system designers are
very much interested in what goes on inside this black
box. We want to know how we can give Bala Inc., the
illusion of having his own platform without actually giving him one.
And including all of the cost, the implementation
and maintenance associated with implementing such a virtual platform.